[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for
February 15th 2019 I'm Sara Crespi in
this week's show I'm talking to staff
writer Paul loosin about whether there's
a hard limit on weather prediction is 15
days as far out as we can get and Megan
Cantwell and Triggs office ooh discuss
his paper on an autonomous bot that's
mapping phytoplankton off the coast of
Norway
how far out can we predict the weather
we've gotten pretty good at it but is
there a limit staff writer Paul Busan is
here to discuss a study that says yeah
about two weeks that's the maximum for
the mid-latitudes anyway hype off hello
so the app on my phone gives me ten days
of weather and it's pretty good I expect
a little variation and that's like
latter days but is that the best that we
can do right now it is the best we can
do right now the top end models from
Europe in the US really they max out at
skillful predictions at about 10 days
we've been getting better at this over
the last few decades what has been that
rate of increase each decade they've
added one additional day of
predictability this is a really great
success but is that gonna stop we can't
just keep adding one day of prediction a
decade forever probably not it would be
nice you know it'd be great for job
security for forecasters yeah but this
is something meteorologists have
wondered about for 50 years and they've
often said yeah maybe it's about two
weeks and this newest study seems to say
yeah it does seem to be about two weeks
how can a study prove a negative that we
can't get better than you know a certain
limit it can't to a certain extent you
know I mean there's always gonna be ways
you could improve this method but yeah
so they took the the latest version of
the European model which is considerably
the best in the world and ran it about
120 times which is you know really
operationally expensive these are
supercomputer type models so they ran a
120 times did they change something
about the initial conditions or what
they were measuring or what they were
excluding in these different session
hmm yeah so you know a lot of the error
that we see in miles could also drive
from our uncertainty about what we're
observing today so we don't have these
perfect understanding of the weather and
so trying to tease out what is a problem
due to our imperfect knowledge versus
the inherent chaos of the atmosphere has
always been an issue but if you do this
kind of big ensemble suite of models run
them all together you can artificially
make it seem like you have no error in
the observations you can narrow the
range reduce it to 10 percent from the
current uncertainty and that creates
this kind of artificial certainty this
is kind of presuming that we're even
better in the future at measuring that
we know more about how weather works and
that we're better at inputting that data
into these models and when all those
assumptions we still get this two-week
limit yep we're possibly better we'll
probably never get that good and it
still it comes to this two-week limit
that Edward Lorenz who is a famous
meteorologist and mathematician father
of chaos theory mr. butterfly mr.
butterfly effect he postulated in a 1969
study that probably seemed to be up
about two weeks a lot of people quibbled
about the model said maybe it didn't you
know really look like the atmosphere but
now these new models that do look a lot
like the atmosphere to the point of even
having convection the kind of cloud
thunderstorm systems forming in them
which hasn't been the case in the past
still run into chaos after two weeks and
are no better than you or me guess in
base off climate records let's go back
to the butterfly effect great mood not a
great mood for people who don't know
what this paper was about I was kind of
surprised that there was a paper I kind
of just thought it was like a thing that
people say from sci-fi it was that -
this is the flap of a butterfly's wings
affecting weather yes yeah so Lauren's
kind of seized on this a sight guys I
think - the paper is from 1969 I think
he coined it and early 70s on referring
to this but is there something profound
about this dependence on initial
conditions but it shows that when you
have these nested chaotic systems that
is just impossible to predict beyond a
certain limit because this
error starts at these very small scales
and then infects each level up and up
until it's destroyed the whole system
this is something even if you have
perfect knowledge of initial conditions
that can't be helped
wait so if you have perfect knowledge of
the initial conditions you still can't
know because because the math is too
hard I don't know cuz no math can help
you okay so that really does put a live
a hard limit on what we can know about
the future of weather probably what
about these long-term predictions where
they say this is gonna be a hot summer
or a snowy winter how does that fit in
with this finding that's a different
kind of forecasting this is more about
the day to day kind of weather forecasts
those are called sub seasonal the
seasonal prediction and they use
seasonal patterns something is called
like the Matt and Julian oscillation
these things I can govern you can't make
this you know oh it'll rain six months
from now in X place but you can make
this kind of broader prediction oh it
might be rain or than a normal month and
that's a very active area of research
and promising so looking at broader
patterns to be able to make broader
predictions but not sinking into like
July 14th and just telling you that's
that's your sunny day that you should
get married on yeah the these seasonal
predictions there's really the marriage
of weather research and climate science
so speaking of climate science how does
climate change affect our ability to
predict the weather if we're trying to
do these data t predictions are these
models gonna hold up if a lot of things
change about the planet the chaotic
short-term weather I don't think it will
these models aren't initialized with the
data every six hours or 12 hours and so
they you know that represents the world
as it is right then and that's just like
you know a quick snapshot I mean here's
projecting these atmospheric flows out
from it so it doesn't necessarily depend
on climate knowledge just the weather
processes those are the same and we just
look at initial conditions they get our
prediction yeah but maybe these broader
oscillations where you're looking for
seasonal changes those might obviously
be more difficult to understand under
climate change yeah they might be more
difficult or they might be just more
challenging you know it's not predicting
a static world it's of a changing world
so you're trying to use it just makes it
a little trickier I
say but that's why this field is really
coming from climate science as well but
people are already trying to understand
this and they were trying to understand
for twenty years from now and it started
to be ten years from now and now it's
moving into these seasonal predictions
we talked a little bit about the
benefits of knowing the weather in
advance mm-hmm hitting this two-week
limit is that gonna make for a big
improvement and some of these things
that people will rely on knowing the
weather for I think every day you add is
a huge game for the economy especially
people who really depend on knowing I'm
sure there's an infinite about money in
wall street interested in this air Lyons
farmers all the people that really just
depend on this way
it'll be a great boon for them like that
example you gave us someone getting
notification that there would be snow on
their flight yeah they'll leave
scientists on this study yeah as he was
finalizing this study he got a
notification that he is flight to London
was going to be problematic five days
out and that he should rebook it for
free about with the airline and he was
like well I should listen to the weather
forecasters here's one and he took the
early flight at a lovely day in London
and then his flight was canceled the
original alright well thank you so much
Paul yep thank you Oh Busan is a staff
writer for science you can find a link
to his article and the research we
talked about at science max last podcast
stay tuned for Megan Cantwell's
interview with trig VII soon on using
autonomous robots to map phytoplankton
patches off the coast of Norway
[Music]
phytoplankton microscopic plants of
plankton play a vital role in the
productivity of ecosystems but
characterizing exactly where they are in
the ocean is challenging
I'm here with today groffle soon to talk
about how he and his team created a 3d
model of where these phytoplankton occur
using an automated underwater vehicle
how are you doing kids so your study was
conducted in Norway what brought your
team to this specific study site we did
this study at an island called Linda at
this island there has been a famous bird
mountain that is home to a number of
different seabirds that forage on
different fish in the ocean outside
however during the last decades there
has been a sharp decline in the number
of birds so betters trying to understand
what this is happening we try to collect
data across the whole ecosystem around
this island phytoplankton are at the
base of this food chain so in order to
characterize exactly where these
phytoplankton are before going into your
methods to evaluate this what was
traditionally done to do a survey like
this traditionally it has been done from
boats ships by deploying instruments
overboard either pulling them straight
up and straight down and looking what
you have or actually in some cases
towing them behind the ship what were
the limitations to those kind of methods
ships are still the most important
sensing platform in oceanography but
it's it's limited in sampling on the
sparse scales it cannot do detailed
service of the water column
he cannot maybe move that fast and their
mobility is limited so ships are
important but they're not covering the
process you want to study at a scale
which is good enough for definite
representations phytoplankton are also
not consistent in where they are the
concentration varies a lot how does the
distribution of the phytoplankton
usually impact the ecology of an area we
usually call this pettiness and it
relates to a number of Io
physical processes biochemical processes
in the water column in different ways on
different scales and it's a very hard
question and there are a lot of people
trying to understand these intricate
mechanisms our paper tried to map this
out in a way so that we have a measure
on how patchy and how this distribution
actually is to get a better sense of the
3d distribution of these phytoplankton
your team used an autonomous underwater
vehicle or an AUV
to characterize exactly where these
phytoplankton are how did the AUV survey
this area to create a model what we have
developed is the system that allow the
AV to take decisions based on the
observation it does during the mission
so this way we're utilizing all the
information that is available to us in
the beginning it's actually focusing in
a volume of water so it's follows on the
sides of a volume and based on what it
sees when it's traveling a rope along
the sides of this box it estimates how
the distribution of phytoplankton is
inside the robot tries to optimize its
route through a given volume of water
trying to give the best map of the
amount and distribution of phytoplankton
and it does that by utilizing a
statistical model that it builds during
its journey through the water and it
continuously update this and the
subsequent data collection is planned
based on the estimate that gradually
gets better and then the sensing
strategy also gets better
what kind of sensors are on this a UV
and how does that specifically help you
measure the amount of phytoplankton in
the water column by the plankton is
usually measured as a proxy true
chlorophyll so by measuring the presence
of chlorophyll we're actually trying to
get the bulk measurement dozen how much
quite the plankton there is we use
statistical framework called the caution
processes to try to do this in a
effective manner so that we can take
this measurement of
Oroville and tied to concentration model
plan our data collection so baby tries
to stay in the region where it has the
most concentration it's actually
interesting to get the map of the
highest concentration because you can
usually tie this to other types of
measurements which we have done in the
paper how big was the area that you
characterized and how long did it take
for the AUV to generate a 3d model of
the area 700 by 700 meters and AV uses
40 minutes approximately to cover the
size of the box and once that model is
made and we have estimate it uses 40
minutes to traverse the insides of the
volume the whole thing takes
approximately one and a half hours oh
wow
that's really fast yeah needs to be fast
because as I said there's current so if
we spend too much time the we don't get
the snapshot we only get some smeared
out snapshot that is actually very time
dependence we able to get other
measurements besides chlorophyll from
this hour-and-a-half traverse so it
arguments to all their measurements so
you can say something about it's the
concentration based on a salinity layer
order high to blanking distributed along
this gradient of temperature salinity or
whatever or is there some other physical
effect that is keeping them where they
are and then you can look also at the
interaction with the zooplankton which
is measured from the boat in our case we
had a something called a silhouette
camera which measures and counts the
number of different zooplankton species
so that you can see how this
distribution is affecting the pipeline
because if if the zooplankton is eating
the part the plankton you will have a
low concentration but this concentration
can also be because there is a physical
force in the ocean at this point there
are current or something else and in
order to make claims about that
you need to know how these things are
related I essentially need more than one
data set in order to be sure that your
statement is actually correct based on
this survey did you find any sort of
relationship between these other factors
and the presence of phytoplankton so
this paper was basically a it was more
methodology focused they're still
looking at the data for this one because
you know we have so much data and
there's so many write small things to do
so I guess the mystery of why the birds
are declining is still not solved then
yeah it's essentially a picture that you
need to build over time when trying to
find out something about the birds
because we took a snapshot of that area
and then that tells of something about
the state of that ecosystem at that time
and in order to say something about why
the birds are declining we need to go
back and take that snapshot once again
and then really go detailed into what
changes are we seeing from snapshot day
to snapshot be thank you so much
sure pleasure to be here today guava
zoom is a researcher at the Applied
underwater robotic laboratory in Norway
you can find a link to his research
article at science mag or
slash podcasts and that concludes this
edition of the science podcast if you
have any comments or suggestions for the
show write to us at science podcast at
aaaa SOR G you can subscribe to the show
anywhere you get your podcast or you can
listen or on the science website that
science metalwork slash podcasts to
place an ad on the podcast contact
mid-roll com this show was produced by
Sarah crusty and Megan Cantwell and
edited by Potter G Jeffrey cook composed
the music on behalf of science magazine
and its publisher triple-a s thanks for
joining us